the Joe Rogan experience I've never done
yoga once it's great I know Peter say
it's good I don't know I know I'll come
I don't want to do hot I don't know how
good you know not scared I don't dig
best waited hmm
Jamie the best way cuz you stretch out
better
you're just ganging up on me plus it's
good for your body because it develops
heat shock proteins that mimic what's
like being on regular yoga fine yeah
it's good okay we'll do that then why
don't you do hot yoga
why don't we reg do regular yeah why
don't you do hot yoga because that's
Catherine I don't really be the guy in
how he did 15 of them in a month he
doesn't even work out he takes our
shadow cyst you gonna trust a guy that
dosis people trust him well he wouldn't
dose me he's my friend it's okay someone
to say that to Burt David next I would
say [ __ ] he dosed Burt because he's a
[ __ ] he don't lie about it because he
felt he'd get away with it mmm-hmm it
was a lapse in judgment that he has
since apologized for no I know I love
him I'm kidding how about this I'll do
hot yoga if you come play basketball
with me and Jamie hole do that but miss
basketballs hard on the joints man all
that side-to-side motion come on come on
baby Street basketball or in the court
we're gonna we're gonna do what would we
play basketball with him could that be
tough
well we'll do anyone or so we'll do 21
you know smoking I know but that's fun I
don't know how to yoga I'm tear I'll be
I'll look like a combination you're
gonna competition it won't really be
that competitive how well do you play do
you play good well yeah yeah it'll be
fun fun for you it's the same yoga [ __ ]
I don't know how this how we did you
Jitsu first okay and then we'll see if
you can play yoga okay that's fine okay
yeah let's do yoga that okay I just I'll
do I'll do the hot yoga no I can play 21
I mean I won't win you know what the
problem is with yoga for me for Jamie
can [ __ ] sink some three-pointers I
don't even know if you know how good
Jamie is video doing jump shots just
swish catches the ball swish dude yeah
dude Anna no really now I bet Jamie
smokes you v in the city I got all my
money young Jamie okay good
much how much do you tell me here we go
here we go here we go baby how it UPS
put up that coin how about $1,000 okay
okay okay okay would eat what are we
doing we plan I'm not one on one we're
playing sure we're doing okay that's why
you guys could play horse okay I got
$1,000 on him
I'm can't wait to film it Jamie you in
you can smoke okay then we'll do home
run dirt I'm gonna spend that thousand
bucks I'll take us all out to dinner
okay
whatever's left I'll give to the waiter
okay good Fran I'm in alright I can't
wait well should we film it yeah we
should where do we do it though I don't
know Staples Center we should make a
basketball court next door we might have
a little bit there's a couple of feet
right it's plenty of room man the
sectarians you want to do a pool show
and I've been talking about this Jamie
and I been talking about this for how
many years now all all of them that I've
filmed a few times like one time we
filmed Fitzsimmons and I playing pool
was fun he's good at all right [ __ ] yeah
40s Leigh yeah yeah who's the who's the
best that you played Artie Lange Artie
Lange can play yeah you can yeah you can
play you can play play yeah you can he
doesn't have like this so some guys are
good at pocketing balls all right you
know I mean some guys are good at moving
the ball around I don't know any
comedians that are really good at moving
the ball around look that with that
positioning you have to have a stroke
like meaning can you draw the ball full
table length
I know I know comedians other than
myself that can do that no comedians
other than myself that have actually
played in real tournaments you know and
I don't play that good now but when I
was playing a lot I could pull it I was
like a B player you know B level player
legit B lever player like I've run four
racks in a row of nine broken ran four
racks in a row I've run 70 plus balls
playing straight pool that's not like
world-class not professional level but
I'm a like a legit what they would call
a shortstop yeah you know and then
what's our tease around that same level
no no he's a little lower than lower
then yeah but he play Dahmer era can
play a little bit Adam Ferrara can play
and we yeah he plays pretty good yeah
why don't you do a pool show I should do
a pool show and why not
here's the thing how do you make it
entertaining I mean you know just wanna
leave will be maybe you're just talking
[ __ ] playing pool having fun yeah
maybe we'd have to give people wired
mics and we it would have to yeah I mean
it could be fun
it can fun everyone but I mean how many
people can play how many people can
legit
well here's one thing that I could do
that be fun bring in pros and just get
stomped that would be fun Asha don't
watch them do tricks on him [ __ ] on your
girl pros in and have them stomp me yeah
and you know what's that a gentleman
turn into Black Widow Jeanette Lee she's
[ __ ] awesome she's very good but
she's not the best no she's not stretch
the imagination oh she's really good but
she's had some severe also severe back
problems she had scoliosis a bunch of
back surgeries but she's you know she's
way better than me yeah she's like she's
legit could a pro be able to teach a
comedian well enough to compete against
you know it's like golf it takes years
it would take years like I could not
play for a year like okay like you could
take a person that doesn't know how to
play and they could play every day for a
year and I'll still crush them
[Applause]